United States top Diplomat is attending
the second and the final day of meetings
with high-level officials in Beijing
within the past half an hour Anthony
blinken shook hands with senior Chinese
Diplomat Wang Yi as the two delegations
sat down for talks Lincoln is the first
U.S Secretary of State to visit China in
five years
well Katrina you joins us live now from
Beijing Katrina presumably there have
been some big issues on the agenda so
far
that's right so on Sunday qingang met
with Anthony blinken at China's foreign
minister met with Anthony blinking for
more than seven hours obviously much to
catch on between these two sides both
sides said that these talks were candid
and constructive now according to
China's foreign Ministry a readout that
they released they said uh that qingang
mentioned that the relationship between
the U.S and China had reached a record
low and that this benefited no one and
that it was important to work towards
improving it to work towards areas of
mutual cooperation it also said that
qingang made clear China's core
interests especially the Taiwan issue
marking this out as a red line that the
U.S should not cross now Anthony
blinken's side said that he made clear
that this was all about keeping lines of
communication open despite the fact that
both the US and China have many profound
differences now it seems that there was
many more things on the agenda including
issues such as trade and Technology
human rights and Fentanyl but it seems
literal agreement was made over these
issues and Katrina if there is no
concrete breakthrough on anything will
this visit be considered a failure or at
least a start of something
I think both sides here were keeping
expectations extremely low just
considering how bad tensions had become
between both sides and analysts widely
agree that some dialogue at least is
better than none and it is significant
in itself that Lincoln is actually here
in Beijing the first uh uh of um his
rank to really visit China in five years
there was some agreement made according
to the Chinese in terms of increasing
people-to-people exchanges making it
easier to travel between the two
countries for example increasing student
exchanges also there was discussion
about agreeing to increase flights
between the two countries routes that
had been cut during the pandemic for
example and also this trip will be very
much about setting the stage for more uh
dialogue between both sides going
forward so dialogue between high-ranking
officials in the future and also a
possible meeting between President Xi
Jinping and der Biden later this year
Katrina you live from Beijing thanks for
that update
well staying with this now Benjamin
herskovic is a research fellow in the
school of Regulation and Global
governance at the Australian National
University joins us from Canberra
welcome to the program so to what extent
is the fact that there's face-to-face
talking at all some kind of achievement
it's great to be with you look I think
it is a significant development it is a
significant achievement for both sides
as your correspondent rightly pointed
out both Beijing and Washington were
keeping the expectations for this
meeting very very low and that's very
good reason that the relationship
between these two great Powers is
divided on basically every front there
are so few points of disagreement and of
agreement rather and they're so strong
points of disagreement across the board
of issues and so I think we're in this
place in the bilateral relationship
between China and the United States
where the simple fact that two
significant influential figures from
both governments get together and have a
marathon discussion of many many hours
is an achievement in and of itself
dialogue discussion meetings that's the
important thing we're not looking here
for any significant breakthroughs any
significant developments we're just
looking for both capitals to be actually
engaging with each other to be
discussing to ensuring that they're not
further doubling down on their missed
trust and misunderstandings of each
other but with those divisions that you
mentioned is it the case that whatever
happens neither side will want to be
seen to be giving away too much as it
were when it comes to actual policies
I think that's absolutely correct that
they are both totally committed to
Prosecuting their agendas and the
reality is unfortunately for both the
United States and China and the wider
world that those agendas are
diametrically opposed they are
fundamentally at loggerheads the United
States right now for example is in the
business of trying to squeeze Chinese
technology companies to cut them off
from the supply of Leading Edge
semiconductors China's in the business
of wanting to increase its Innovation to
grow its economy to emerge as one of the
greatest powers in the world stage and
when you have two capitals at
loggerheads like this there is so little
ground for agreement and it's also
entirely possible that areas of policy
where they should be able to agree and
cooperate will fall victim to these
competitive adversarial Dynamics and
we've seen that vis-a-vis responses to
climate change both China and the United
States have an interest as all countries
do in responding effectively to climate
change but from both sides they see any
initiative from the other side as being
something which will give the other side
an advantage and therefore is something
to be suspicious of and maybe even to
undermine so I think we're in this phase
where there is so little chance of
actually making significant progress on
any of these issues because they are so
diametrically opposed given what you say
then how difficult will it be to find
any kind of common ground for example on
the deeply entrenched issues of Taiwan
and Ukraine
I think we are locked in a bit of a
staring match on these kinds of issues
China has demonstrated time and time
again that it won't pull back from its
relationship with Russia despite
Russia's illegal and immoral invasion of
Ukraine that relationship is Rock Solid
China continues to provide Russia with a
certain level of diplomatic support and
the economic relationship between those
two countries is booming and that's
something which is going to deeply
frustrate and even anger Washington long
term at the same time the United States
is committed to deepening its unofficial
ties with Taiwan the United States is
committed to maintaining in perpetuity
taiwan's de facto Independence and as we
know from political leaders in Beijing
that is also a red line for China China
wants to achieve the unification of
Taiwan and China over the course of the
next few decades and so both of these
countries on all the issues that we
could look at substantively in the
international Arena are really at
loggerheads and they are driving in very
different directions I think maybe the
one Bloomer of Hope in all of this is
that this meeting is is maybe the
Prelude to a more substantive discussion
between presidents Joe Biden and Xi
Jinping later this year it's possible
they'll get together on the sidelines of
the Apec meeting which the United States
is hosting and maybe that will yield
more substantive discussions at the very
highest level which maybe provides us
with an opportunity to go in the right
direction bilaterally but of course as
we all know U.S domestic politics is
gearing up for a really bruising
presidential campaign and China policy
is going to be at the center of that so
expect temperatures to only rise
Benjamin heskovic we very much
appreciate your insights thank you
thanks great to be with you